und wir wollen weiter diskutieren mit
csu-generalsekretär markus blume der uns
jetzt zugeschaltet
guten morgen herr blume hallo ich grüße
sie kriegsgott hallo herr blume wir alle
hatten wir uns doch darauf eingestellt
60 70 prozent der bevölkerung müssen
geimpft sein und dann kriegen wir
endlich die freiheit wieder
und jetzt sagt er gestern die
bundeskanzlerin ich muss es selbst
ablesen die ziel impfquote von 90
prozent bei den über 60-jährigen und 85
prozent bei den 12 bis 59 jährigen
das sind immer neue werte da fühlt man
sich doch veräppelt wie soll das
weitergehen
jetzt ist leider so dass corona immer
neue und häufig auch negative
überraschungen für uns bereit hält wir
sehen dass bei den neuen varianten der
impfschutz nicht so ausgeprägt ist wie
das am anfang an der fall war und
deswegen ist das im ziel jetzt ein
höheres gleichzeitig ist impfen der
einzige weg zur normalität und deswegen
kann ich dringend nur an alle
appellieren dass wir uns
gemeinschaftlich in deutschland hier auf
den weg machen
für mich ist impfen ein akt der
solidarität und ja auch geradezu
patriotische pflicht
nur so können wir sicherstellen dass wir
in künftigen fällen eben keine
beschränkungen mehr brauchen ich bin im
übrigen auch der meinung dass wenn jeder
in impfangebot hatte und das auch
wahrnehmen konnte und vollen impfschutz
hat das dann die umfassende
fürsorgepflicht des staates ist ein
stückweit endet und vor allem dann auch
wieder eigene verantwortung gilt und
trotzdem letzter satz müssen wir schauen
dass wir unser gesundheitssystem nicht
auch in künftigen fällen an die
belastungsgrenze führen deswegen bis wir
das ziel erreicht haben sind die
grundlegenden regeln weiterhin wichtig
danach setzen wir ja man hat das gefühl
die ziele so hoch dass man fast schon na
ja jetzt schon eine rechtfertigung
braucht um dann eventuell im herbst
winter wieder alles dicht zu machen 85
prozent jetzt diese neue zahl im raum
das können wir auch gar nichts erreichen
impfen ist ein wettlauf gegen die zeit
wir müssen schneller durch geimpft sein
als die nächste welle heranrollt das ist
unsere gemeinsame aufgabe und da kann
jeder einen dienst auch für seine
mitmenschen leisten
es gibt menschen die aus verschiedenen
gründen sich nicht impfen lassen können
weil es eine indikation gibt die dagegen
spricht umso wichtiger ist dass alle
anderen die sich impfen lassen können
das auch tun
wir haben deswegen in bayern jetzt dass
wir gesorgt dass so niederschwellig wie
noch nie geimpft werden kann
man kann den impfzentren ohne termin
gehen man kann quasi an der
supermarktkasse am parkplatz bei der
sportveranstaltung geimpft werden also
impfen wird so einfach sein wie noch nie
und insofern appellieren wir auch in
jedem dieses einfache impfangebot
tatsächlich zu nutzen
schließen sie denn aus dass es
irgendwann mal dann doch wenn es sich so
vorangeht wie geplant eine impfpflicht
in deutschland geben wird
eine impfpflicht war bei uns nicht das
thema und sie wird nicht das thema sein
ich appelliere an die kollektive
vernunft der deutschen dass jeder weiß
was notwendig ist wie alle wünschen uns
nichts sehnlicher als normalität und
volle freiheit das impfen ist das ticket
dazu und wenn die vernunft uns da nicht
weiter bringt auch die kanzlerin blieb
er gestern so ein bisschen show blick
und sagte im augenblick appelliert man
so an die vernunft
was ist denn wenn die vernunft uns nicht
aushilft es ist eine klare hierarchie
anreize
wir müssen jetzt alles tun als gegen vor
pflicht wir müssen jetzt alles tun dass
die anreise so groß sind dass dann auch
tatsächlich sich möglichst viele impfen
lassen eine impfpflicht ist in anderen
ländern nur die ultima ratio
ich gehe davon aus und hoffe dass wir so
etwas bei uns nicht brauchen
sie gehen davon aus sie hoffen das
klingt aber zumindest nicht danach dass
sie es auch völlig ausschließen können
diese ultima ratio blume vielen
herzlichen dank dass sie sich zeit
genommen haben für dieses gespräch
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren